there are few names in sports as
recognizable as basketball legend
michael jordan
i mean even if you know nothing about
sports you've probably heard of the guy
not only is he one of if not the
greatest athlete of all time he's a
spokesman for dozens of different brands
he's a billionaire
businessman and most importantly he's a
meme i mean really
is there anything that this guy can't do
well yeah it's called
acting has anyone here ever played
basketball oof
it's almost like this guy's a
professional athlete and not an actor i
really enjoy playing with you guys you
guys got a lot of vibes
well whatever it is you got a lot of
let's just hope that lebron had a better
acting coach for the sequel
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that always asks y'all ready
for this
and by this we mean lengthy analytical
deep dives into movies he loved when you
were in elementary school
my dear theorists it should come as no
surprise to those of you who know me
well that i wasn't exactly the sportiest
of children growing up in the 90s they
just weren't as
interesting to me as video games or
movies or math
or phantom of the opera you all laugh
but that phantom's got himself some mad
ups no in all honesty pretty much
everything was more exciting to me than
watching the old sports ball but there
was
one notable exception the cinematic
masterpiece
known as space jam combining cartoons
with one of the most popular athletes on
the planet talk about a slam dunk now
the plot
isn't exactly the most important thing
but if it's been a while here's the
original space jam
story in less than 30 seconds some small
aliens get sent to earth to abduct the
looney tunes and take them back to their
alien theme park planets bug's bunny
obviously not
wanting to be abducted notices that the
aliens are small and challenges them to
a basketball game in exchange for their
freedom
good plan except for one thing the alien
steal the talent from five professional
basketball players on earth to turn
themselves into the ultimate basketball
team
the monstars with their freedom on the
line the looney tunes kidnap michael
jordan to help him win and after a
hard-fought poorly officiated game the
toon squad comes out on top
also bill murray shows up randomly which
might be the most realistic part of the
movie idea deity
that's all folks this movie
single-handedly got me interested in
basketball sure i might get picked last
in gym class but if elmer fudd can dunk
one how hopeless can i be i'll let
sniffles the mouse sum up my playing
philosophy
i'm small but i'll try really really
hard to be good at basketball and i
always try hard my mom says try your
best in everything
sure the movie might not have taken home
an oscar but it won something better
1.2 billion dollars in merchandising
revenue so you can kind of see why a
sequel was inevitable starring the new
michael
jordan aka lebron james so yeah gotta
say kinda hype for space jam new legacy
now i haven't seen the movie yet so i
don't know a whole heck of a lot about
the team that lebron has to face other
than they look like rejected aliens from
men in black but i gotta say these guys
have got themselves some huge shoes to
fill i mean the monstars in the original
movie were an unstoppable team
huge intimidating and harnessing the
best talent that the nba had to offer at
the time lebron had better be
thankful that he's not facing up against
that right well
no looking back on space jam the mom
stars were actually a team that was
built to fail from the start as scary as
they were i'm confident in saying that
if the monstars were to play in the nba
these days they'd finish
dead last in their league don't believe
me well let's lace up those air jordans
and pour yourself a tall glass of mj's
secret stuff cause it's time to come on
and slam
the monsters as the crummy team that
they were and how they'd only be worse
in this new movie if they were to return
now to really
start talking about how good the
monstars weren't we actually have to
consider their individual players or
rather the real nba players that each
alien stole their talent from
obviously the monsters didn't precisely
turn into the players whose talent they
stole to the best of my recollection
patrick ewing was incapable of breathing
fire but based on the original form of
the aliens and their ignorance about
what basketball even was it's safe to
say that the aliens didn't
add any sort of basketball skill to the
equation so to simplify the argument
we're going to say that the tune squad
was essentially playing a game against
the five players that the monstars stole
their basketball talent from
individually all five of these guys were
good players but together
it's gonna make for a strange team the
typical positions on a basketball team
are point guard
shooting guard small forward power
forward and center and historically
teams have one player at each position
playing at any given time guards tend to
be smaller faster better shooters and
better ball handlers
power forwards and centers are bigger
and slower they play closer to the
basket to block
shots get rebounds and score from close
range now the monstars clearly valued
their big guys since
four of the five players they mimic are
either power forwards larry johnson and
charles barkley or centers patrick ewing
and sean bradley and the monstars had no
middle ground because their fifth player
is muggsy bogues the shortest man to
ever play in the nba at just five feet
three inches tall so it's not a roster
with a lot of balance but hey weren't
those just the five best players in the
league not exactly
barkley and ewing are hall of famers
sure but in 1995 and 1996 the season
that space jam takes place in they'd
both been pros for a decade and were
well past their prime as for the other
three players they're all better
basketball players than i'll ever be to
be sure but sean bradley mugsy bogues
and larry johnson were named to the nba
all-star team
just two times combined in 36 years
of playing professionally the point is
that the monstars were a horrifically
unbalanced team consisting of players
who were far from the five best
non-jordan players at the time and
that's just talking about the error that
the movie came out i've seen a lot of
people bummed out about the fact that
the monstars aren't returning for this
new movie but i gotta tell ya they'd be
a
far worse team now because of the way
nba basketball has evolved over the past
25 years
in fact if they did reprise their role
in space jam new legacy they'd get
blown out not just by lebron james but
by even mediocre teams because one
they're too slow on the defense two
they'd tire out too easily and three
they can't shoot let's take these one at
a time shall we issue one the monsters
would be too slow to play modern nba
defense
a number of factors are crucial for
playing good defensive basketball but
speed and quickness are arguably the two
most important if you can't keep up with
the player on offense that you're
supposed to guard you're gonna be giving
up easier shots when players go around
you and you'll have trouble recovering
when the offense runs a play to exploit
your lack of speed the monstars
despite being explosively strong
athletic and creatively violent aren't
very quick now speed and quickness can
be hard to quantify so we're turning to
an old friend to do the job for us
video games nba live 98 is the oldest
nba game with comprehensive ratings on
player attributes grading on between 50
and 99 on everything from awareness to
dunking ability the game was released
about six months after space jam hit
theaters so it's a pretty good data set
for us to use now nba live 98 has some
great things to say about mugsy bogues's
speed and quickness
rating him at 82 and 97 respectively for
the other four players though their
speed averaged out to 63.8
and their quickness was an anemic 52.8
even if you exclude sean bradley who at
a whopping seven feet six inches is one
of the tallest
but slowest players in nba history those
numbers only jump to like
67.3 for speed and 58.7 for quickness
still well below the average so what
would this mean for the monsters in a
typical game well
for one it means that they would be
awful at defending the fast break where
the opposing team gets a rebound and
sprints to the other end of the court to
score as quickly as possible
but even in a slower game the lack of
quickness would be problematic take for
example one of the most popular actions
in the nba
the ball screen in a ball screen the
offensive player with the ball leads the
defender into a screen set by their
teammate to get away from the defender
then the teammate who sets the screen
most commonly rolls to the basket known
as a pick and roll leaving the ball
handler without the option to pass
drive or shoot without the foot speed to
handle ball screens switch defensive
assignments or defend against the fast
break the monsters would be given up
tons of points no matter how many shots
they block around the rim because
they're playing against a much faster
team a team that's literally led by
rabbits issue number two the monsters
would get exhausted in every game they
play
another odd decision by the aliens was
to only steal the talent from five
players nba rosters typically have 13
though the past season it was expanded
to 15 and it's exceedingly rare for
fewer than eight
to play in any individual game so
without any players on their bench
all five monstars are forced to play the
entire 48 minutes of the basketball game
which is far more than any of these
players would typically play
issue number three they can't shoot if
you watch an nba game these days you'll
notice how much work teams have put into
getting open
three-pointers it wasn't always that way
though the three-point line was
introduced into the nba in 1979
but it wasn't all that popular at first
coaches hadn't factored it into their
offensive strategy and players hadn't
grown up practicing it so it took
decades for it to become as popular and
as effective as it is now and while each
of the monstars had some elite skills
none of them were good three-point
shooters in the 2020-2021 nba season the
average
three-point shooting percentage for all
players in the league was 36.7 percent
the year before space jam came out only
one monstar
larry johnson even approached that
number shooting 36.6
everyone else on the team is far below
charles barkley
28 bradley 25 mugsy bogues 20
and patrick ewing shooting a ghastly
14.3
and here's the thing those numbers are
actually inflated seeing just how
unpopular the three-pointer was in the
80s and early 90s the nba
actually moved the three-point line
almost two feet closer to the basket for
three years from 94 to 97. factor
that into the calculations and the
entire monstar's roster would shoot 25.4
percent from three
no single team in the nba has shot that
bad
in this century and it's not just the
rate at which the monsters would be
shooting those threes that would hurt
them it's the sheer number of threes a
modern opponent would be shooting
against them in the last year before
space jam with a standard three-point
line
nba teams only attempted 10 threes per
game last year they attempted
35. so even if the monstars somehow
didn't get tired and figured out how to
defend in spite of their lack of
quickness the fact that even an average
team in today's nba scores much more
efficiently means that the monsters
would get crushed over and over and over
again
lebron should hope that this mysterious
goon squad in the new movie is exactly
as good
or i should say not good as the monstars
were now maybe you're thinking that if
the monsters were really as bad as i'm
saying they were wouldn't michael jordan
and the toon squad have blown them
out of the water in the original movie
and it's certainly a reasonable thought
but go back and watch the movie again
when i watch the game again as an adult
i can't help but feel that it's been a
bit
rigged i mean come on look at all the
fouls that the referee
isn't calling here and remind me again
who was the referee oh yeah
marvin the martian but matpat he's
impartial because he's both toon
and alien you really expect me to
believe that the looney tune whose
primary objective in all his cartoons
was to disintegrate other looney tunes
and also blow up earth wasn't pulling
for the aliens tell them what i think
about that logic mj
stop it get some help but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and you know
i've actually been doing a lot of binge
watching and prep for this new space jam
movie not only does it feature all our
favorite delusional doodles the looney
tunes but there are just a ton of cameos
from a lot of other warner brothers
classic characters we're talking
scooby-doo and the whole mystery
incorporated team pennywise the clown
are those the
droogs from a clockwork orange what
what i'm saying is that in order for me
to be fully ready to comprehend the
massiveness of this movie i've got a lot
of catching up to do and luckily today's
sponsor nordvpn is here to help
nord is the trusted online security
solution used by over hundreds of
thousands of internet users worldwide
myself included did you know that with a
vpn like nord you're given access to
streaming sites around the world that's
right with nordvpn you can get access to
other countries versions of your
favorite streaming sites giving you the
ability to stream movies and shows that
may not be available for you at home
with over 5 400 servers in 59 countries
you can essentially
unlock a never-ending streaming library
nordvpn is literally the only reason
i've been able to watch every season of
rupaul's drag race internationally
there's so many of them at this point
australia thailand uk they're impossible
to watch here in the us but guess what
with nordvpn just
one click boom and suddenly my internet
looks like it's coming from a completely
different place where all those seasons
are available to me to watch at home
what i love most about nord is that it
helps me stay safe on the internet with
nordvpn your info stays safe behind a
wall of next generation encryption
it masks your ip so that you can keep
your browsing to yourself so let's just
say you're studying the fine nuances of
lola bunny's redesign
for research no one will have the
ability to track that data
not even nord with their strict no logs
policy they don't track
collect or share your private data your
business stays
and remains your business so get in
order today and also help support this
channel by clicking the link below in
the description or
going to nordvpn.com film theory that's
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y
use the code film theory to get yourself
a two-year plan at a huge discount
plus a free bonus it's all risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
again that's nordvpn.com
film theory and use the offer code film
theory at checkout to take advantage of
nord's worldwide servers and ensure your
privacy online
and cuts